- On this episode we talk charisma,
the lonely road of success and hashtags.
♫ Hey
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show ♫
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 159
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Monday morning, nice and cool.
7:30 teacher conference
for Misha this morning,
which was fun.
Always good to hear that
your child is amazing.
In first grade there's only
so much damage one can,
I mean, even I was a great
student in first grade.
In a good mood, the Jet's squeaked it out.
There was one point, before
they gave up a late touchdown,
that the score was very
close to my prediction,
which I was happy with.
But very concerned about Thursday's game.
Do we have a, I know I'm
going to Orlando Wednesday.
Do we have a show tomorrow?
- [DRock] Yep.
- And, oh, do we have
one Thursday morning?
- [Voiceover] Said yes.
- Okay, great.
You'll get it out before
the game, perfect.
So I'll make my official
prediction Thursday.
You'll probably get it in the afternoon,
early afternoon right before the game.
Plenty of time for all you
gamblers to put in your,
but I'll give you an early
indication I'm very concerned.
Any time you play a team that hasn't won
12 games in a row on the
road like the Jags hadn't
and you win the turnover
battle four to zero
and you only win by five points.
There's a lot of stuff going
on, there's a lot of injuries.
The Jets are banged up, so that's that.
Had a good, apologize I
actually was super sad.
Missed the entire week.
Last year was, not last year.
Last week was probably one of
only two times or three times
since we started the show
where I missed an entire week.
So that stunk, sorry about that.
But I'm glad to be back in the saddle.
India, it's good to see you.
- Good to see you, too, Gary.
- Good to see that
you've stayed consistent
with your black attire.
(laughs)
- You know I didn't want--
- But I cut my hair.
- Oh my God.
- [India] Yeah.
- That's a big deal.
- That's very short for you.
- It is very short for me.
- Cut, wow.
- [India] Yeah.
- What happened there?
- I was just, went for a
haircut and then I was, like,
"You know what, it's time
to donate most of this."
- How much got cut off?
- Like, almost two feet.
- Wow.
- [India] Yeah.
- That's incredible.
- [India] Yeah, big things.
- I could use some of that (laughs).
All right, India.
- [Both] Let's get into the show.
- Also, also little new
thing that I started doing.
I just emailed you guys
randomly on this, right?
Random VaynerMedia employee
to just join every time.
By the way, yeah there you go, good job.
Why don't you tell the Vayner
Nation real quick who you are
and then we'll get into the show.
What you do here.
- Hi Vayner Nation.
I'm Don Camana, I'm a
community manager here.
- [Gary] Where'd you grow up?
- [Don] Jersey shore.
- [Gary] And what
football team do you love.
- The New York Jets.
- Yeah, nothing random about that!
Actually it was, you picked it.
- [India] Yeah.
- Good job, India.
You're, and you watched the
Jets yesterday a little bit?
- [India] No I didn't, I'm sorry.
- Oh, India, you had momentum going.
- [India] I was watching the Niners.
I know.
- But the Niners played
late, the Jets played early.
- [India] They were just
on TV when I was in a bar.
- No, no but the Jets were
early, the Niners were late.
- But I was at the bar
when that game was on.
Like, I wasn't at a bar before.
- What were you, like, what
did you just, like, sleep in
and miss the and wake up at like four?
- [India] No.
- Were you raving till
four in the morning in Queens?
- Yeah, it was crazy.
- Yeah, all right,
let's get into the show.
Enough banter for a Monday.
- [Voiceover] SaltySnapz
asks, "People say the road
"to success is lonely.
"Do you feel that's accurate?
"If not, why do you think
it's a common sentiment?"
- You know, I think
people use that statement
because the truth is, I mean first of all,
it depends on how you define success.
In the context of what this show is about,
which is business success,
obviously we talk about a
lot of life stuff as well.
But, you know, when you're the CEO,
when you are the founder,
the conversation that's not being had,
everybody sees all the nice
things that come along.
But every single thing that
happens in this company
that's wrong is my fault.
Every snarky comment on social.
Every kind of, like, sad face.
Every email bullet points that I,
every Friday I get bullet
points from tons of
Vayner Media employees and 80% of them
have a bullet that's like,
"Rick is stretched too thin
"and is crying in the bathroom."
That's devastating.
It's very tough to be
at the top of something,
even when it's going great.
Vayner's going great.
This is not even, like, you
know Wall Street collapsed
and we lost a lot of clients
and we have to have layoffs.
This is, like, we're
rolling and we're the best
and we're crushing and there's
always things to worry about.
Because you know that there's no,
"Oh, it's India's fault."
Everybody here, at some
level, all the way up
can still say (snaps
fingers), "It's Gary's fault."
I can't and when you say it's my fault,
there's a really tough burden emotionally,
forget about financially,
that comes along with that.
And so I think it can get
very lonely, you do recognize.
It's amazing to me, for
as much of a communinary
and extrovert as I am, how
much I keep in my own mind.
How much is going on in
this noggin every day.
Calculating, strategizing, thinking.
And there is no vacations.
I desperately love national holidays
and, like, I can't wait for
Christmas and Thanksgiving
because everybody else is checked out
and that's the only time,
that's the only time
that I'm able to be off.
I have my 40th birthday
coming on Saturday.
I'm going away with my family.
This is an incredible moment in my life
and I will not be able
to be 100% checked out.
Because then those, you know
and that Friday and that Monday
the world is moving, this world is moving.
My responsibilities are moving.
I'm always one phone call away from a fire
that I have to address.
It is a very intense, lonely
place to be, at the tipy top.
And so, when you think about,
you know, I always think
about, like, "Is life fair?"
Right?
There's always things that happen,
there's things that we can't control.
But the notion of, like,
somebody getting compensated
a lot of money for things that we,
do I think somebody making
20 million dollars a year
to be an athlete or an actress.
We never talk about
actresses and actors, right?
We love to zing on athletes
but, like, actors make, like,
the big ones make like
eight, 15 million dollars
to make a movie.
But still, at the end of the day,
it's because they command the market.
People want to pay attention
and there's enormous amount of pressure.
As I've lived my life and
started spending some time with
A-list celebrities, there
life is, I mean, it's intense.
Like, I really secretly
think that I could be
an A-list celebrity.
That I literally could go
on TV and be a breakout hit.
Like in a Mad Money
kind of like, you know,
not like Jennifer Lawrence.
I just don't have the looks.
But in a Mad Money, kind of like Regis,
kind of like Andy Cohen way.
But man, real celebrity status is intense.
You just have nowhere to
go and so there's that.
Or an athlete where the
physical shape that you have to,
18, you know, 10 hours a
day of putting in that time.
People look at the outcomes
they don't think about
what's coming along with
it and the pressure.
The pressure to know
that if I get hit wrong,
that my entire life collapses,
especially an athlete
that has a short window.
Or the pressures that we've, look,
I don't think it's a coincidence
that some of the greatest
artists of all time pass
away in their mid-20s
because of the intensity.
It's intense, it's intense.
It's very lonely and so it
could be extremely lonely.
I, ironically, and you'll
find this wild, I love,
look I want random extra
people in the room.
So, like, I love being around
people more than anything
but I'm also very comfortable in my own,
being one-on-one with myself.
So I'm good but I know that I'm
emotionally stable as fuck
and it's intense for me.
I can't imagine people that
are not as fortunate as I am
pulling from both directions.
Ambition but humil, you know.
Like, do you know how content I am?
A lot of people watch
this show and you hear
I wanna buy the Jets and you misunderstand
really where I'm at.
I want it all and I
wanna win the whole thing
but if I never win again,
if I plateau at this level,
there's an amazing amount
of content in my body
for all my hunger.
And that balances me
but I couldn't imagine
if that was tweaked just a little bit.
If I really felt the pressure
because there's enough pressure from
a day in and day out standpoint.
It's intense, it's intense.
I think people say it I
think much like stereotypes
or statements there's
always so many truth to it.
I think the reason so many people say
the road is lonely because
to really be successful,
in the context of business especially,
you've gotta make seven to 7,000 decisions
that are critical and you can
only make them with yourself.
It's an intense moment on a daily basis.
Yeah.
Little bit of a rant to
start Monday morning.
Let's go a little lighter there, India.
- [India] Um, okay, uh, Kyle.
- (laughs) Uh-oh.
Kyle.
- [Voiceover] Kyle asks, "You
thanked Travis Kalanick in '09
"before we knew who he was.
"Who is someone we don't know today,
"but will in the future?"
- Are they commenting
or are they liking it?
- [Don] I was getting hammered
at first for a bad angle
but I think I cleaned it up.
(everybody laughs)
- Okay, got it.
Okay, good, good to know.
Wasn't really asking about
how they were dissing you.
Are they enjoying the content?
- [Don] Yeah.
- Okay, good, good,
good, good, good, good.
(everybody laughs)
- [India] From Kyle.
- Kyle.
- "You thanked Travis Kalanick in '09,
"before you knew who he was."
- Oh, this guy's asked
this questions a thou.
I was, you really made him
sweat this one out, India.
- [India] I didn't.
- I saw this question
on social a lot.
- [India] Really?
- Yeah, yeah I saw it.
Anyway, go ahead.
- [India] "Who is someone
we don't know today,
"but will in the future?"
- The reason, who asked that?
- [India] Kyle.
- Kyle, the reason I didn't
send India this question
and say, "Hey, you need to ask this."
Because I saw you
pounding it over and over.
So, great perseverance.
Way to get on the show.
Is 'cause I don't think
I have an answer to that.
There is one entrepreneur, a
guy by the name of Ben Cera
who created Facefeed, who's
doing some consulting now
on the west coast, who I think is magical.
C-E-R-A and there's an
amazing amount of people
that I think are real winners, just tons.
But nobody that makes me feel like they,
Ben Cera's the only one
that makes me like he's got
a trillion dollar execution in him.
So that's the answer.
And the truth is, it's still
early intuition on Ben Cera.
Compared to with Travis, I just knew.
Which only speaks to the
Uber miss on the angel round
multiple times even more baffling.
It's really the great mystery of my life.
- [India] That's unusual.
- [Voiceover] And your last, "Hey Gary,
"to what extent would you say
"your success is due to your
showmanship/charisma factor?
"Thanks!"
- Angel, I think my
showmanship and charisma
is a major fact, my
charisma is an absolute,
being charming is a stunningly
important personal trait.
Being likable is really
cool and I, especially,
have a weird thing going on
because in my public persona,
especially when I'm on
stage or performing,
I get very competitive.
Very, like, I wanna rap
battle the world, right?
Like I want to beat everybody.
So I'm combative and I say
things that most people
don't want to say so it makes
a certain group uncomfortable
and actually makes them
not like me as much.
So then when they meet me one-on-one,
and that charming, kind
of real person plays out,
I even get extra credit.
Yeah, listen, I think it's a major factor.
Now, on the flip side, I
can rattle off 50 people,
which I won't 'cause this is a dis,
that are massively charming,
massively charismatic
but have no depth.
It's classic sizzle and steak.
I think I have both.
Now do I think a steak that
really sizzles sells better?
It sure does and so I would
almost say maybe it's 50%.
All right, if you wanna go
basic, it's 50% of my success
because having the goods
to back up that hyperbole
and charisma and
excitement and showmanship
is a major thing.
There's a lot of people faking this show.
There's a lot of content
on YouTube and out there.
There's a lot of people that are trying,
there's a lot of people
doing quote pictures
the way I do them or videos the way I,
I'm not talking about you, DRock.
(everybody laughs)
And doing videos the way I
do and there isn't traction
because I think people can smell it.
So you have to be able to back it up.
But I don't run away from it.
I definitely think that, I
hate when people don't think
that they're lucky.
Like, I don't how to not quantify
my charisma, my personality
as anything short of
I took great features from my parents.
Who just, my parents
deciding to get married,
unfortunately even though, if
my dad ever watches the show,
which he doesn't, mom, make
sure you show dad this part.
As much as I'd love to
take credit for mom and dad
getting married, I just can't.
My dad always likes to zing me
for taking credit for stuff.
Yeah, I think my personality
is a major factor.
I'm also equally happy to
know that my work ethic
and my tenacity and my
skills and my compassion
are equally factors in my success.
- [DRock] Does your mom watch every one?
- I think my mom's watching
almost every one, yeah.
(blows kisses)
- [India] From Ram Castillo.
- Ram?
- [India] Mmm hmm.
- G'day, Gary, Ram Castillo here from
GiantThinkers.com.
- [Gary] Giant thinkers.
- Recording this from Sydney, Australia.
I am an author, a blogger,
a podcaster, a speaker
and CreativeLive instructor
that helps emerging
designers be employed.
I have a "what would
you do" question, Gary.
Currently I have one book
and CreativeLive courses
for all of us bloggers
and podcasters out there
that are looking to better monetize.
What would your next right hook be?
Would it be to create another book,
potentially a video course or
even a membership component?
Cheers.
- That's a good question.
Ram, right?
Ram, great question, big
shout out to Australia.
Looks like Australia next
March for the book tour
is becoming very realistic.
So going down under could be fun.
Haven't been there since
I've been in the wine world.
Not true, actually just
remembered I flew in and flew out
for a business talk
three or four years ago.
Ram, I think it comes down to
what's the best product you could put out?
Whatever form you think
that you can execute in.
Whether that's a second book
'cause you're a great writer
or an online course 'cause
you're charismatic on video
or a membership site because
you think you can provide
enough value worth paying for
in a differentiated market,
and yes you can taste my cynicism there,
or continuing to build
up your brand to become
more of a persona that
gets to publicly speak.
I think speaking is a very
lucrative way to monetize
one's personality.
I think it'd be really interesting
if, since it sounds like
you're teaching other
people to become employed,
I think it'd be really
interesting for you to
do more of that yourself.
So instead of teaching
people how to make money,
maybe you go out and get employed more
so that you can speak to, like,
"I did a million dollars
worth of gigs this year."
I think you know that from
me, I'm cynical to people
just teaching for the sake of teaching.
So I enjoy the fact that I've built,
of course with AJ and team,
but, like, I've built a
machine that does, soon to be,
a hundred million dollars
in social media work.
It sure give me a lot of
oomph to say now, like,
this stuff works 'cause these companies
don't keep us around
'cause I'm charismatic.
And so, you like the recall there?
Recall.
Go ahead, Stephon.
Stephon?
(laughs) Hey, Stephon.
Hey, Stephon, over there.
(everyone laughs)
Talk to Staphon.
And I'll take a recall
(laughs) component here.
Little rusty, a week away and...
I think all of those are viable options.
And for everybody who's watching,
you can tell the back-end
ones were the ones
I'm more excited about because
I love proof in the pudding.
That make you think of Bill Cosby, too?
Is he that associated with pudding?
For me it is.
- [India] No.
I was thinking of--
- He's in an interesting spot these days.
- [India] I was thinking
of porridge pop-up.
- What's that?
- [India] I was thinking of--
- Oh, the porridge pop-up.
- [India] Pudding pop-up.
- Wait.
We have to punt that, right?
Because, like, people
expect us to do it now
and I don't think Steve can pull it off.
(laughs)
I mean, I haven't heard from in a week.
(everyone laughs)
- [India] Last one from Kylie.
- Kylie.
- [Voiceover] Kylie asks,
"You never use hashtags.
"What the hell."
- That's a really good point, Kylie.
I saw that question,
too, come through social
and I wanted, I mean,
I dodged that (laughs)
as quickly as I could.
That's a shortcoming,
I'm not doing a good job.
I'm really screwing up
Instagram, 'specially.
I'm not happy with myself.
This is a lazy, and I never
talk of myself in lazy,
I'm doing a poor job.
As a matter of fact, I'm gonna fix this.
Team, we need to get our shit together.
I need you to help me here.
Can we get, like, seven to 10,
we did this once and I
didn't execute on it.
This is the second time around.
We need, I need to understand
better what hashtags
I need to be using on Instagram.
I just don't have the time
to put in for the homework.
Find the white space, not the ones,
not "entrepreneur" because that has a lot.
Like, what's the long tail version.
Kylie, great question.
India, great job of asking the question.
This is a shortcoming.
You know, I, like any other human,
go through the ebbs and flows
of not doing things well.
As a matter fact, I don't think
I handled my personal brand
all that well up until
the #AskGaryVee Show
because I was so busy executing.
This one's even worse because
I'm actually doing it.
There's no reason I shouldn't
be adding four to seven
strategic hashtags per post
for discovery of new people.
I just need to get better.
It's a lack of practitioner execution.
One that angers me that
we had to address it
and maybe even ruined my week
now that this has been exposed.
(everyone laughs)
No, listen, it's a great question.
This is one of the few times,
and this hurts my feelings,
but this is one of the
few times I need to say,
"Don't look at my behavior.
"Do it the right way."
You need to be using.
It's a free discovery
tool in these channels.
I think I'm mailing it in,
specifically on Instagram.
So, what the hell is,
I'm dropping the ball.
And that hurts.
- I'm sorry that we ended on a sad note.
- That's all right.
I won't call it sad anymore.
I'm now motivated.
- [India] Great.
- It's a motivating note.
Thank you guys for watching the show.
Is there anything, I feel like
there's something I wanna say
but, DRock, is there
anything we wanna say?
We have no films in the making.
Oh, we have a speaking trailer coming out
but that's kinda not
that big of a (mumbles).
- All right.
- [DRock] We have two films.
- Yeah, we have two films?
How close?
When will our next film be out?
- [DRock] Next month.
- Next month.
Because you're hedging my time.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Good job.
All right.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)